imusama was first introduced in chapter
906 of the manga and fans were
immediately shocked to learn that this
being is the true ruler of the world
government the one who sits Atop The
Empty Throne nobody besides the very
upper echelon of the world government is
even aware of imusama's existence and
yet this being is the one who calls the
shots the one who decides what will be
erased from history we know that imusama
has a special interest in four
individuals Luffy Blackbeard Vivi and
shirahoshi and emu is also in possession
of a giant straw hat which has been
locked away inside a massive freezing
vault in marijua some 180 chapters after
imusama's introduction it was revealed
that emu has some sort of connection to
Lily nefertari the queen who ruled
alabasta 800 years ago is imusama
actually Lily The Immortal Queen of the
world subscribe to anime outpro right
now and you'll find out as soon as we
find out